julianne hough is engaged the Dancing  with the Stars judge will be showing off  her moves at a wedding Hough Instagram  to this photo Tuesday morning it's her  giving her now fiance Brooks Laich a big  hug and showing off that all-important  finger she captioned the pic we are  overwhelmed with joy and excitement to  share with you our recent engagement the  32 year old is an NHL player for the  Washington Capitals he and 27 year old  Hough have been dating since December  2013 not long after they got together he  told 106 7 the fan but he was a quote  pretty lucky guy and obviously he still  feels that way  now the big question is what song will  be their first dance congratulations to  the happy couple